[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Today's mining operations comprise
a series of disparate siloed environments,
from extraction and automation systems to port and rail and track automation.
Each environment presents its own challenges
and mainly operates independently using proprietary data sources and networks.
You need a holistic view of your entire mining operations
that leads to better visibility and traceability
while letting you take advantage of rich IP
enabled technologies in each environment.
Working with industry leading partners, Cisco can help fully connect
and integrate all of your operational environments,
removing the barriers to efficiency created by siloed networks.
But it doesn't stop there.
Cisco takes an integrated approach, converging your existing enterprise
systems with this new consolidated operational technology, or OT network.
The result is a fully connected and converged pit-to-port network
that enables lean, efficient, collaborative, safe, and highly
secure operations while helping you keep your costs down and your profits up.
With Cisco Solutions for Mining, you can improve performance and efficiency
at all stages of operations to reduce downtime, better manage and schedule
your fleet and assets, wherever or whatever they may be,
increase security to control access to restricted areas and your assets,
and most importantly, better ensure the safety of both
your employees and the environment.
And you can do all of this while connecting your teams and assets
collaboratively around the world.
Here are just a few examples.
In mining operations, downtime is the enemy,
and an idle truck can cost hundreds of thousands per day.
Cisco Solutions for Mining help automate operations for maximum efficiency
by leveraging the Internet of Things, where
every device interacts with each other and turns information into action.
That means critical elements on a truck, from engine components to tire
pressure, can be monitored both onboard and remotely,
enabling predictive maintenance.
Cab sensors monitor drivers for alertness,
and should a driver become tired, automatically
notify both the driver and a remote operation center.
Monitors can also remotely alert vehicles approaching a pit too quickly,
helping to ensure the safety of the driver and others working in the pit.
Real-time remote monitoring and scheduling of all machines and vehicles
is possible at every operation phase, from excavation,
to raw material movement, to delivery.
Cisco's Solutions for Mining also help to create a zero-harm environment
for personnel and surrounding areas.
This includes using RFID tags to track miners and machinery underground
at all times.
If there's an incident, each worker can be located in minutes.
Similarly, gas monitor systems help enable remote real-time gas detection,
so personnel and responders can be alerted to up to the minute conditions.
Even with mining operations located in remote areas,
malicious attacks can still occur at any time.
Cisco Solutions for Mining add both physical and cyber security
to your infrastructure, helping to protect your operations and assets
from both internal and external threats.
And Cisco Solutions for Mining let the mining operators remotely collaborate
on ideas and solutions with your office personnel, outside maintenance crews,
and third party engineering companies from around the world without ever
leaving the site.
To find out more about Cisco Solutions for Mining, visit us on the web.
[MUSIC PLAYING]